we're looking at substitution today what
is substitution was it employment right
this is quickly remember algebra algebra
we said it's this relatively new you
know historically speaking relatively
new kind of bats and I called it I
called it a game changer right it's this
new ideas way of approaching things that
allows you to solve and approach all
different kinds of problems right give
me the key idea the key idea in algebra
is well how would you express what's the
key idea yeah good so we had some words
for these by the way as well
I'm one of them is for example
ponyville's right so we tend to use
letters to indicate numbers that we turn
no numbers that we don't know so not
only are they called pros it's just
sometimes called variables because they
can vary they can change another day
which I sort of said but I write down
which you can write down now these
unknowns right there numbers it's like I
know what they are but I can still work
with them ok so if this is the key idea
right you can work with numbers before
you know what they are then this is how
you kind of will take that idea and now
put some like real numbers into it right
so substitution simply means to work for
well actually can you give me a synonym
for substitution or substitute instead
of saying I'm gonna substitute this for
that what other word could you put in
there any suggestions here Jordan for
swap wonderful substitution swapping any
other suggestions yeah replacing also
perfect right if the idea of taking
something else and putting something in
its place in fact that's exactly what we
placing meat ok so here's an example
right we've got all of these expressions
here and if we can replace the pretty
rules with the values that they've been
to stand for there will have data
substitution ok so this is the way I'd
like you to sit down this is the way I
do it right where you get given Pro new
rules and you get
all what they are and this happens in
real life and in tests all cut all the
time I often like to write down what
they are I have them all laid out in
order and then what I have these things
here put that a little bit of working to
make sure I do the substitution right
okay so even though I can look at this
and then look at that and I could
straightaway say that the answer is
eight the answer is eight I am going to
go through and put these just two extra
lines of working to show how I got that
here's the first one
what's the actual question and then I
just was substitute one at a time what
should I write yeah so it's a a plus B a
plus B sure okay well that'll become
clear as we're at least there right so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take
these numbers and you don't do like this
bit but I'm going to replace them right
I'm gonna swap them out rights instead
of a alright three and instead of B all
right fine so that step there that's the
substitution step now we've started off
with really simple stuff stuff you could
do in your head but it's gonna fairly
rapidly go to stuff that you don't want
to do in your head and you want to write
down this step this step is cause this
substitution step right it's literally
the point we just take all the numbers
all the right values and you put them in
the right spots now I can evaluate it
that's so now we have the basic idea I
think we can get through the wrist rest
of these quite quickly right for a what
will be my substitution step what should
I write down
I should write four times three right so
you'll notice without algebra you could
just get away with saying for a but you
when you've got numbers in there you
can't just write for three because that
means something else different doesn't
it so it really does mean four times
three which is 12
okay so what else really what should I
write for this death
someone help me without yes pregnant -
totes - I could write 2 times 2 or just
as equally because it's the same I can
write 2 squared they're both equivalent
which is false
great okay so that was already the next
question we look here and it's really
important you can see it's starting to
put in more things together and the
operations are gonna start to get a bit
tricky right you don't have to but you
may like to help yourself clarify what's
going on by pointing brackets right that
will help you remember what you should
do first and in what order
okay so that's gonna be 12 minus 4 which
is 8 okay you could put down 12 lines
more if you'd like but I think we can go
straight to aim that's okay the last one
here - eh that's 2 3 all divided by so
what's that equal to you could do some
canceling here on the fractions right
yeah that's again so what else what I'm
try yes on you good it's great and you
can see that if you take this - you
can't tell up with that - all you're
left with is 3 ok so you can see like I
keep saying working really that is this
step this step and so on these are the
most important steps in the working and
the final number is less important ok so
that's a bit of start as you go through
the questions you'll get more complexity
but the basic idea is there